c'est ce commun
une voix douce enivrante un son
personnel et authentique qui nous touche
droite au cas c'est la musique d'elena
de l'air
[Musique]
l'album s'articule autour des angoisses
qui surgissent lorsque nouvel amant
entre dans notre vie est vraiment une
métaphore pour laisser aux fantasmes de
se réinventer soi même plutôt que de
rencontrer quelqu'un d'autre qui veut
des ultimes ans nous permettre d'aller à
cannes nouveau aussi ici il s'agit de
son premier disque elle a déjà fait
paraître cinq mini album et s'est attiré
des critiques élogieuses de la part de
magazines internationaux comme les
inrocks ou le site pitchfork
[Musique]
c'est sûr que c'est comme un espèce de
grandes tapes seul de ces gens très très
très flatteur que le projet intéresse
les médias internationaux
[Musique]
une voix chaleureuse et familière qui
sans être calqué sur qui que ce soit si
nourrit de l' influence de plusieurs
grands artistes york johnny metal death
the legend féminines c'est se met dans
le plus flou qui règne entre kir et
sybille bailleurs il ya un potentiel
émotionnel dans l'écriture de chansons
qui me que j'arrive pas à trouver
ailleurs vraiment mais qui des fois
précède mes propres réflexions sur
certaines choses ça me donne un peu
craie en main pour comprendre ce qui se
passe
un travail que duré deux ans et qui
s'est terminée juste avant le premier
confinement le disque apaisant qui donne
du courage mais maintenant tu es dans le
heureusement ça veut pas être
physiquement rassembleur mais ça reste
quelque chose de t111 ce teaser
réconfort je pense pic est surtout
évident non ces espèces de moments
difficiles qu'on est en train de
traverser une enfant
m
à découvrir ce mot nude elena de leyme
signée alexandre charti radio canada
montréal
[Musique]